Would be you more focused on a task if you knew
someone was watching you with a critical eye?
What if that “someone” was a friendly robot?
Or a mean robot?
To test the effect of robots on human concentration,
researchers gave 58 people a classic test
to measure how much they were paying attention
when there was a robot in the room.
Participants were shown a series of words
in different colors and asked to identify the color
in which a word was printed, ignoring the word itself.
More focus is needed when the word itself
is a color word than when the word is color neutral.
The difference in the time it takes to identify
both kinds of words is called the Stroop factor.
The subjects took the test twice – first alone,
and then again with a new set of words
in the presence of a robot, which was programmed
to turn its head as if it were watching them.
Right before the color test, The subjects interacted
with the robot, asking it a series of questions.
The robot was set to either “good” mode,
giving friendly, positive responses
or “bad mode,”
giving abrasive, negative responses.
Subjects completed the test fastest
in the presence of the bad robot -- faster than when
they were alone or observed by a friendly robot.
Previous research has shown the presence of
a belligerent human can improve our focus on
tasks like the stroop test, but this was the
first time this was studied with robots.
As social robots become a bigger part of everyday life
for things like elder care and therapeutics,
it’s important to understand even the unintended effects
that robots might have on how humans act and think.
So, while the researchers don’t think robots
will end up bossing humans around any time soon,
being a little wary of humanoid bots,
might actually be a good thing when it comes
to focusing on the task at hand.